today on the matt wall show tragedy
strikes as cnn's new streaming service
crashes and burns right after takeoff
it's a terrible thing also republicans
in florida officially passed the bill to
revoke disney's special privileges but
some conservatives are uncomfortable
with this kind of aggressiveness from
the right and johnny depp has audio
proving that he is the victim of
domestic abuse aoc warns about another
january 6th on the horizon and jen
pasaki tries to explain why kindergarten
teachers might need to talk about gender
identity with their students her
reasoning leaves a lot to be desired
we'll talk about all that more today on
the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
with mother's day coming just around the
corner it's time to start thinking about
what you want to do to make your mom
feel special i've been trying to think
about what i want to give my mom this
mother's day season and all i can think
about is the time where i refused to fix
her vhs player over this past holiday
season which i admitted to
now i'm not going to apologize for that
because i refuse to apologize for
anything but instead i'm gonna give my
mom something that she will be thanking
me for so that she should have to
apologize to me at the end of this
i'm gonna give her a reason to throw
away the vhs player once and for all
with legacy bucks legacy box is the best
company out there when it comes to
digitally preserving all of your
sentimental uh things but but also
outdated belongings that's why they've
helped millions of people digitize their
belongings over the past decade just
send legacy box all your videotape film
reels photos there and whatever else you
have in their team over of over 200
trained technicians will hand digitize
everything you can track their progress
along the way with their online tracking
system and once they're done they'll
send you all your original copies along
with digital copies stored on the thumb
drive the cloud or dvd now my mom won't
have to worry about having a working dhs
player anymore and she can show all my
embarrassing videos and photos to my
wife easily over the holidays although
she's already shown all of them to my
wife so it's not going to be any news
there you could do the same for your mom
this mother's day by visiting
legacybox.com walsh right now to get 60
off your order that's legacybox.com
walsh
well it is the first segment of the show
on a beautiful friday and uh i wanted to
do something fun and lighthearted
because i am of course known for being
fun and lighthearted
that's not gonna be possible today as
there has been a deeply tragic event
indeed a series of deeply tragic events
that i must address um
this has been a week of loss heartbreak
grief calamity after calamity
tribulation after tribulation
it all began on monday with the terrible
news that jon stewart's new show on
apple is failing this came as a great
shock to the nation mostly because the
nation didn't realize that jon stewart
had a new show but he does for now and
just five weeks into its run the latest
episode was viewed only forty thousand
times
yes forty thousand now to put that in
perspective forty thousand is a fraction
of the audience that i have for my
podcast and i used to do this thing in
my car in fact yesterday i did a 10
minute monologue about a woman whose
boyfriend is digging a big hole in the
ground
and we clipped that and posted it
separately on youtube for some reason
and even that has more than 40 000 views
more people are interested in hearing me
talk about a hole in the ground
that are interested in hearing john
stewart talk about anything
i'd like to think that's a reflection of
my brilliant oratory about holes but i
think it's probably more a statement
about the near complete lack of interest
in jon stewart
no doubt jon stewart himself is
flummoxed by all this after all he has
used every episode
of his new show to worship the god of
wokeness he has made all the sacrificial
offerings he's burned the incense and
performed the incantations he's
flagellated himself and repented of his
whiteness over and over and over again
he's done everything he could and yet
his ratings continue to plummet
soon he'll have an audience size
comparable to what say your uncle might
get if he did a facebook live for his 32
friends on facebook
the whole situation has led to lots of
analysis and speculation and most
tragically of all think pieces
one thing piece published in the
atlantic yesterday spends many thousands
of words trying to figure out what
happened to jon stewart and why he isn't
as funny and smart as he was back in his
daily show days
it's been a lot of theorizing about this
point and amid all the discussion and
conjecture somehow nobody has remembered
the daily show the daily show jon
stewart was reading lines off of a
teleprompter that somebody else wrote
for him so maybe he's not as smart and
funny anymore because he was never that
smart and funny his writers were smart
and funny and even then not nearly as
smart and funny as everybody pretended
that's one thought
but whatever the cause of this current
situation it is a terrible thing
and i feel bad
very bad very bad for jon stewart
but the tragedy doesn't end there uh the
very next day it was announced and again
this all happened this week
it was announced that things aren't much
better over on apple tv's main
competitor netflix it was revealed that
netflix actually lost subscribers 200
000 total
in the first quarter of 2022
and this news sent netflix stock
tumbling so that now the company has
lost 50 billion dollars
once again analysts are flabbergasted
how could netflix be losing so many
subscribers it's
unexplainable netflix itself blames the
war in ukraine
they say that it's putin's fault and
that's not a joke by the way that's
really what they're saying
yet another outrage committed by putin
first his invasion of ukraine causes a
gas price spike that was already
happening before he invaded ukraine then
his invasion of ukraine causes a supply
chain crisis that was already happening
before he invaded ukraine then his
invasion of ukraine causes inflation
that was already happening before he
invaded ukraine and now
he's stealing subscribers from netflix
i bet he's also the one stopping people
from watching jon stewart by the way
now we know that the subscriber loss
can't have anything to do with the
product that netflix is offering
because that product is uniformly
spectacular
i mean for example just this week
netflix netflix announced a new film
called he's expecting about a pregnant
man
and the trailer for this film by the way
stipulates that this is a cisgender
quote-unquote
pregnant man
obviously the sort of material
people want to see
and would see if not for putin
this brings us finally to the tragic
grand finale
the week's last in dignity
the thing that nearly broke me
the announcement was made at the end of
this week
cnn's new streaming service cnn plus
which was launched only a month ago
will be shutting down it lasted for a
month
a month
the company invested 300 million dollars
into it and it lasted a month
my god my god why have you forsaken cnn
plus why did the world forsake it
reportedly the service was attracting
only ten thousand viewers a day only ten
thousand
they could have literally quadrupled
their audience if they hired jon stewart
you know tim poole has a live stream of
his chicken coop that easily pulls more
than 10 000 viewers in a day his chicken
coop
300 million for 10 000 viewers means
that their cost of acquisition per
viewer was like 30 000 so by my math
if they wanted to reach the daily wire
subscriber numbers at 30 000 a pop it
would only cost them about
um 18 billion
so it's a bad situation in other words
and now cnn plus is no more
once again though
media analysts are mystified especially
the media analysts at cnn
why don't people want to watch cnn plus
sure nobody wants to watch regular cnn
but let's let's try to do some more math
here if nobody wants to watch something
and then you offer more of the thing
that nobody wants to watch
shouldn't that equal like a million
viewers or something
what's zero times a million isn't it a
million i have to check my calculator
however the numbers shake out this is
simply shocking i mean cnn plus had a
show with chris wallace
and he's the guy who had a fox show that
nobody cared about and then he left to a
network that nobody cares about on a
streaming platform that nobody cares
about and somehow yet again
this failed to generate excitement
the real crucial mistake cnn made was
was not immediately striking a deal to
ensure that cnn plus is streaming in
every airport terminal and dentist
office waiting room in the entire
country because that has long been their
target demo indeed their only demo
now look we can
sit here
commiserating about the spectacular
failures of jon stewart netflix cnn
we can hold each other and cry
and we should
but the one thing i've learned from the
media this week and this is the most
important takeaway
is that none of this is a reflection
on their ideology okay
none of this means that people are sick
of woke leftist sermonizing
you might think that that's the lesson
here but it's not
that is not the takeaway literally
anything else is the takeaway blame
anything but that but especially blame
putin
and frankly blame yourselves
for not supporting these wonderful
endeavors
you are all clearly in league with putin
and your dastardly plot has caused grave
injuries to jon stewart and netflix and
now you have taken the life
of cnn plus
you have blood on your hands you
monsters
brian stelter is crying himself to sleep
every night because of you
anderson cooper is traumatized
don lemon is humiliated
look at what you've done to these great
men
shame on you all
may god have mercy on your souls
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
the value of the minivan pickup sedan or
whatever you drive probably appreciated
significantly last year take care of
your automotive investment and keep more
of your money by buying the auto parts
you need to maintain and repair your
vehicle rockauto.com rockcutter.com only
sells auto parts and related tools and
they've been doing it for over 20 years
their unique intuitive catalog includes
photos specs and installation tips that
make it easy to choose the correct parts
for your specific vehicle they not only
have the auto parts you need but we'll
give you a selection of trusted name
brands to choose from you can pick
breaks that match how you use your
vehicle whether that's for towing racing
or just commuting to work you can get
suspension exhaust air conditioning and
other kits that provide all the parts
you need for successful repair
rockauto.com has lots of parts that you
might expect would only be available at
car dealerships if they're available at
all parts like the fan inside your seat
that cools your uh your tush
which is the word that's being put in
this copy for me to read
rockauto.com prices are always reliably
low that means they do not change prices
based on what the market will bear like
many airlines and marketplace sites too
why would you put tuition
now that's out there i actually said
that now
anyway go to rockauto.com for your auto
parts and write walsh in there how did
you hear about us box so they know that
i sent you
sorry about that i got a little more
emotional than i thought it would it
just if i feel
so bad for these
i feel so bad for them um and by the way
on a positive note i got to say happy
earth day to everyone it is earth day i
believe this is a great day great
holiday which was invented by a psycho
hippie who murdered his girlfriend and
put her in a compost bin
um
now you might say that this is something
in earth day's favor because it proves
how committed the founder was to
recycling but i think it more just kind
of goes to show how modern
environmentalism loves all of nature
except for human beings so it's quite
appropriate actually that it wasn't that
earth day was invented by a murderer
and that's my problem with
environmentalists not that they're all
murderers although i suspect probably
most of them are
um
is that i can't give you credit for
loving nature if you exclude humanity
from your affections
if your love of nature
you know if you love nature but hate
humanity then what does your love
actually mean
because first of all nature exists
for us i mean trees and rivers and
flowers are significant because rational
creatures
give them significance
like if you found out that a planet in
another solar system with no rational
life on it but a bunch of trees and
flowers blew
up how would you feel would you see it
as some great tragedy
it's not like any suffering happen only
rational creatures can suffer you could
destroy a billion trees
and it would cause no suffering at all
of any kind unless there are rational
beings around to be affected by it
um
but i think the other thing is this
and we'll get to the headlines in a
second
is that loving
loving nature is easy
you know i mean we should love nature as
long as we don't worship it
like the left so often does as long as
we don't love it more than humanity
but in proportion loving nature is is a
good thing
but it's easy
you know i mean i love nature i actually
love it a whole hell of a lot more than
the average
urban dwelling environmentalist you know
those nature lovers who choose to
surround themselves every day with
concrete and plastic and glass
um
i don't do that i could go out on a lake
and be out there all day
um
uh i'm also i'm gonna start beekeeping
again to go along with my new aquarium
that i'm getting as i told you about
yesterday as a beekeeper i will be doing
and have done more to save the planet
than any vegan that's for sure
but all that said
it's easy to love
beautiful lakes and mountains and trees
and stuff like that it's mostly a
self-serving love like you you love
those things because of how they make
you feel um
you know you find it beautiful and you
like being around beautiful things and
so that's why you love it and that's
fine
but loving people is more difficult
because people are complicated people
have their own designs their own minds
there's you know conflict with people
people can lie they can cheat they can
steal they're also capable of heroism
and selflessness i mean people make
moral choices often bad sometimes good
though
and i just what i've noticed is that
lots of people
in our society have given up on people
on humanity and they've retreated into
this
love of nature or loving their pets or
whatever at the expense of or instead of
people
and that's my problem with it
anyway happy earth day please don't kill
and compost your loved ones today
um all right yesterday the florida house
voted finally in favor of revoking
disney's special legal and tax
privileges
and um that means and and ron sanchez
has already said he's going to sign it
so it's going to happen
let's uh
dip into this and just check out that
glorious moment for a moment here
and we will vote on these two bills
it is my hope that we will be able to
proceed civilly
and with decorum and with respect for
one another read the next bill
by sunder bradley senate bill 4c built
to be entitled and act related to
independent special districts
[Music]
represent fine you're recognizing
explain your bill what they're screaming
in the background there thank you mr
speaker it seems as mickey and minnie
they're big uh big disney fans i guess
this is the bill that we discussed
yesterday
whatever they're screaming they're fans
of grooming children and their big
disney fans those two things
seemed to go hand in hand especially
recently
okay so they voted for it
um
not everyone agrees as you can tell to
put it mildly in fact i got in trouble
yesterday by with media matters for
something that i said about this uh on
on the show yesterday
let's put up the tweet from uh jason
campbell who's the media matters hall
monitor
it says daily wire host calls for taking
mickey mouse's head and putting it on a
spike and it's true it's true that i did
say that but i also said i was speaking
metaphorically you know i'm talking
about decapitating decapitating mickey
mouse in a strictly metaphorical way
what's wrong with with metaphorical
language am i being attacked now for for
for being a poet is that what's going on
here
but maybe media matters is right i mean
this is violent and dangerous rhetoric
about a cartoon character we should not
threaten violence against fictional
cartoon characters
just wait until they hear what i would
do to those bastards of paw patrol
the most annoying cartoon characters of
all time
i take them to the vet to be euthanized
in a second i tell you that but
the left you know is upset about this
and we know that of course
the more important discussion is on the
right whereas we as we talked about
yesterday
some conservatives especially in media
are also upset about what desantis is
doing um with the actions that he's
taking about disney and we reviewed some
of those arguments yesterday now david
french has weighed in and as you might
expect he calls this an about face on
free speech that seems to be the line
that that some on the right are taking
is that by revoking
special privileges from disney it's an
attack on their free speech rights
somehow
jenna ellis is a conservative who i like
and who is often right about things but
she gets this one wrong um here's here's
her take on this let's listen
disney isn't doing anything illegal
or
immoral in terms of action
by their statement now is the statement
advancing an immoral viewpoint yes but
in terms of under the law
disney isn't doing anything other than
exercising constitutionally protected
speech
that is the entire point of this
conversation
and so people on twitter have been so
outraged saying no go salt the earth go
retaliate against disney go tear them
down democrats do this to conservatives
all the time and so ron desantis should
finally go after disney i'm glad to see
a republican finally exercising the same
types of fights that democrats do well
let's think about that for a moment
just because the democrats wield
unconstitutional power and try to get
away with it does not in any way justify
republicans doing the same
okay so let's let's just clear this up
here
um
what they're doing in florida right now
republicans are doing is they are taking
away special privileges that have been
granted to disney
and to no other
corporations in the state
they were their own literal kingdom
their own fiefdom
and uh they were able to govern
themselves and they got massive massive
tax breaks out of it
that have certainly totaled in the
billions of dollars since this uh
policy was put in place back in the 1967
i think
so
that's what we're talking about
special privileges
so how can it be an attack on free
speech to revoke special privileges do
they have do they have a right to those
privileges well they don't because
that's why they're privileges
do they have a right to the tax breaks
do they have a right to
to self-govern their 40 square miles of
land or whatever they own
is that a is that a constitution where
is that in the constitution exactly
where is it in the constitution that
says
that disney
has a
right to tax breaks
no you're taking those privileges away
that they have no right to so as far as
i'm concerned um
there goes the free speech argument it's
got nothing to do with free speech
there's no they're not passing a law
saying that um disney as a corporation
isn't allowed to express their views
in favor of grooming children that's not
what it is
it's just that you're not gonna get
these privileges anymore
and why aren't you going to get them
well
i don't see really
why there needs to even be a specific
reason
you had these privileges no one else had
them now you don't get them anymore
is it a constitutional obligation to
justify the
revocation of privileges
justified in a way that disney will find
sufficient is that is that the
constitutional obligation of ron
desantis i don't see how it is
but actually there is a very good reason
in this case
um
aside from exacting revenge on disney
which is the part about it that i like
but that's probably not the the kind of
legal argument
that ron desantis would make
i think the only argument to make is
that it doesn't serve
the interest the public interests
anymore to give them these privileges
it does not um
serve the interests of people in florida
to give these privileges to
disney and so they're not going to have
them anymore
why doesn't it serve the public interest
well for one thing because disney is
using
its vast resources
to promote the sexual indoctrination and
abuse of children
and if they're going to do that we're
not going to provide them a tax
sheltered
forum and platform to do it
so it does not serve the public interest
anymore
to give them these privileges
whether it ever did is a entirely
different question
it certainly doesn't now
so it's just it's hard for me to
for to tolerate this
you know on the left
they they sick the government on
you know cake bakers
who actually are exercising their first
amendment rights
they'll go after anybody
and we're not talking mega corporations
which is what disney is we're not
talking about a multi-billion dollar
uh
global conglomerate
they'll go after just some some guy
bacon cakes in colorado
and relentlessly they'll never stop they
still haven't stopped
they'll keep going until they destroy
you
and that is simply because they don't
like your speech and your values
and they can do that
and then we decide simply to revoke
special privileges from a mega
corporation
because they're advocating for the
sexual grooming of children and we have
people on our own side saying this makes
me uncomfortable i don't know about this
it's just i'm uncomfortable with it
that's what it is they're just they're
uncomfortable with it and they're
they don't know exactly why they're
uncomfortable with it and so they're
just like looking for a reason to
justify their discomfort and that's how
they fall in this free speech thing
which makes no sense at all because you
do not have for the 50th time you don't
have a first amendment right to tax
privileges
it is a privilege
so that's what i see is is
you don't really have much of an
argument against it but you're looking
for one
and why are you looking for one i guess
because
for some people on the right
to see others on the right going on the
offense
going on the attack being
proactive instead of constantly playing
defense it's just they're not used to it
and that's what makes them uncomfortable
it's it's kind of a shock to the system
understandably in some ways actually
because we're not used to this kind of
thing
i mean what's
the last um
republican
leader you know political leader at any
level
who's the last one to do
something similar to what ron desantis
is doing right now
i don't think we've ever seen anything
like this
because we're so used to republicans
just being milk toast and and as we
talked about yesterday just being kind
of speed bumps lying down on the road
and uh hoping that you can slow the
progress of the of the left slightly as
they run right over you
you're used to that it becomes a shock
to the system when you don't see it and
i also think
that there are some on the right who um
actually prefer losing they prefer to be
in the controlled opposition camp and
they kind of just and it's it's easier
to to do that to to lose there's not as
much pressure
you don't have to actually lead you
don't have to have a vision
if all you do is lose
and you have your role and you play it
and
and it gives you something to complain
about oh the left they're such bullies
well we're done with that now now we're
going on the offense this is great
okay let's go
here johnny depp is in a defamation case
against his ex-wife amber heard and um
i haven't followed the case that close
because i don't care all that much but i
thought this was interesting yesterday
here's audio of his wife
and they've both got
audio and video of each other they've
just been filming and
documenting each other apparently
throughout their marriage it's really a
healthy sign of a healthy marriage is
when you're constantly you constantly
feel the need to secretly record your
spouse so here's one recording of uh
johnny depp's wife ex-wife now amber
heard admitting that
she hit him although she has an
interesting
distinction that she tries to draw in
order to justify the abuse but listen
i said to you
hey okay tell travis what just happened
are you telling me to do it you told me
to you said go do that i said no tell
them what you're saying i lied and that
you punched me in the
thing and you figured it out and you
said
i didn't
i'm sorry that i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched don't tell me
what it feels like to be punched you
know you've been a lot of fights you've
been around a long time i don't know
you didn't get punched you got hit i'm
sorry i hit you like this but i did not
punch you i did not deck you i
was hitting you i don't know what the
promotion of my actual hand was but
you're fine i did not hurt you i did not
punch you i was hitting you how are you
how what am i supposed to do do this
i'm not sitting here about it am i you
are that's the difference between me and
you your baby
because you started you are such a baby
[Applause]
johnny
okay
i think we have enough of that
these are just such broken
people in hollywood
broken empty
people which is why their marriages
never work out
you take two broken empty people and you
put them in a marriage together it's
very rarely is going to work um
so her
argument is that uh i didn't punch you i
hit you so that's i'm not i'm not quite
sure i understand the distinction
between the two things
and a couple things here
first of all i know part of amber
heard's claim is that she was abused and
and uh terrorized by
and terrified of
johnny depp but you listen to audio like
that and it's that's i don't exactly
hear a woman who's terrified of her
husband or who's abused when when she's
admitting to physically striking him and
and uh
is mocking him
does that seem like a woman is afraid of
her husband
i just hit you you're being a big baby
is that what you say when you're afraid
of somebody
but then the other thing of course is
that is that the the massive
the
massive glaring double standard
and if there's a double standard with
anything it is with this is with uh
situations like this marital disputes
especially domestic abuse issues
you just
imagine that audio the other way imagine
there's audio of johnny depp
saying to amber heard i didn't i didn't
punch you i hit you you big baby can you
imagine that if that audio was out there
but we have that amber heard and they're
still they're actually people that still
take her side
because even the people
and indeed in fact actually especially
the people who claim that men and women
are exactly the same there's no
difference this distinction is entirely
arbitrary
um
they say that and yet they just they do
not put
mail on fema they don't put female on
male domestic abuse nearly on the same
plane as male and female that's the fact
okay aoc was at a town hall yesterday
and she had a lot to say including um
about january 6. she's still panicking
about january 6th and she says that it's
not over
you know they're out there gathering
their forces and they're going to invade
the capital again listen to this
if we lose the house
this is no joke january 6th was a trial
run
and a lot of people don't seem to
understand that it was a trial run
[Music]
and they're going to come back and they
win the house here's the thing the
technicality of what happened on january
6. the only reason it wasn't worse was
because democrats had the house and they
didn't have the votes in the house
if they take the if they take the house
then they have the votes to not
authorize and legitimize the
presidential election
whatever the results are
and so
this is very serious
yeah she's trying as hard as she can to
make this seem like um
an ongoing threat like there's some sort
of ongoing threat
of and of course this is what we hear
from from these people all the time
there's this ongoing thread of
violence on the right and writing and
they're going to do january 6 is going
to happen all over again obviously
saying that while entirely ignoring the
fact that um
on the left they just kind of write
whenever they feel like it and it really
is it's it's really just whenever they
feel like it you know blm whenever they
feel like they'll ride they're not
riding right now because they don't it's
just it wouldn't be to their political
advantage right now too
and uh maybe they're just taking a break
they don't feel like doing it but
whenever they feel like doing it they
just do it
on the right on the other hand
um
this is
quite literally the one example
of people on the right participating in
a riot
so you've got one example that anyone
can cite in the last
many decades
and
we certainly know it's never going to
happen again because for one thing um
there is not this overwhelming
proclivity towards that kind of thing on
the right which is why it only happens
once in several decades whereas on the
left hands all the time
but also the entire force of the federal
government
came
down on these people and is still
raining down on them
throwing the book at them and then
throwing some things at them that aren't
even in the book
which we know has not happened for the
blm writers another quick uh piece of
audio i want to play for you fauci is
still on the scene and um
desperate for relevance
you know he's
you got to understand how hard it is for
him i mean we talked about the tragedy
of cnn plus and jon stewart in the
ratings and how they've collapsed
in a way fauci's own ratings personal
ratings have collapsed i mean he was on
tv
pretty much every day for two years and
he and he loved it
and
now they're not coming to him nearly as
often
which is why now he'll appear on you'll
see him i don't know who he said he's
talking to some mainstream reporter here
but he'll he'll appear on just like
youtube channels and podcasts with with
50 listeners because he's so desperate
for attention
but finally they've come down and asked
him his um take on the jug judge
striking down the mask mandate on planes
and you'll be shocked by his opinion on
the matter
both surprised and disappointed because
those types of things really are the
purview of the cdc this is a public
health issue
and for a court to come in and if you
look at the rationale for that it really
is not particularly firm
and we are concerned about that about
courts getting involved in things that
are unequivocally public health
decisions i mean this is a cdc issue it
should not have been a court issue so
we're hoping
that the inevitable increase in cases
which we're seeing are not going to be
associated with an increase in
hospitalizations
so all of these dynamic things going on
at the same time it was perfectly
logical
for the cdc to say wait a minute
we were planning on ending this mandate
on a certain date let's wait a period of
time until may 3rd
which was a very sound public health
decision
so for a court to come in and interfere
in that
is really unfortunate it's unfortunate
because it's against public health
principles number one
and number two is because that's no
place for the courts to do that this is
a cdc decision and that's very bad
precedent
when you have courts making a decision
and looking at what the basis of the
decision was it was not sound
no it's it's actually not it's not a cdc
why should that be a cdc decision
we know over the last two years the cdc
has
declared that it has
the power of the legislature the
executive branch the judiciary branch
we know that it's it's it has claimed
these powers for itself but
um
it's never had to
justify that
why should the cdc get to set policy
on airlines
well it shouldn't of course but i will
tell you one thing um
as as wonderful as it is to have this
mass mandate
gone
especially as someone who flies all the
time and i'll be uh on the road again
next week and this will be and i'm
looking forward to it as my my first
experience
on an airplane in two years where people
aren't wearing masks
and that's gonna be a wonderful thing
but you know what there's also a part of
me that just that that says um from a
political standpoint
like i i dare you i hope
that you try to challenge this thing and
overturn it and put masks on people
again on planes
like that's that's
on one hand i don't want it
and we shouldn't want it but on the
other hand i feel like we should be
saying yeah go ahead and make our day go
ahead and do that
heading into the midterms
you've already got a lot of nails in the
coffin i'm not sure that we can fit one
more but maybe we can because that'll be
it
give people a little taste of that
freedom and then put the masks on them
again
that's why i still i just can't
believe as cynical as i am
i cannot believe that they buy
administration would be that politically
suicidal to actually launch now they'll
make a show of it i understand that
because they have to make a show of it
and they'll at least pretend that
they're challenging the uh the ruling
and they're trying to get the mask
mandate put in place again but um i it's
it's
hard for me to believe that they would
be that politically suicidal
but we'll see speaking of politically
suicidal um
self-immolation so one other thing i
want to play for you rudy giuliani
appeared on this show the masked singer
and
that's a show that
every time the show is explained to me i
i i
have to look it up because it always
sounds like a joke i still can't believe
the show even exists but apparently it
does and it's been around for a while
now it's on like it's i don't know it's
on it's been around for several seasons
and i guess what the whole show is that
somebody shows up in a big costume and
they sing and then the judges have to
guess who's in the costume and that's
the show people watch this show
uh rudy giuliani appeared on the show
and uh and then there was the big reveal
and he took his his costume off and he's
singing a song and one of the hosts was
so upset to see rudy giuliani that he
stormed off the set in the middle of the
of the taping let's watch this
before i met you and i'm done
break a thousand more babies
before i am through
i want to be yours pretty baby
yours and yours alone
i'm here to tell you honey
that i'm bad to the bones
bad
[Music]
everybody involved
is embarrassing themselves there there's
there is no dignity
anywhere to be found in that room or
anywhere near this show at all including
people who would watch it
but the story of rudy giuliani i mean
utterly disgraced himself
what do you what do you there's there's
no amount of money
that they could possibly pay you if
you're rudy giuliani that would make
that worth it i don't care
i don't care if they if they offered you
100 million dollars to put on that
costume and sing that song
and pop out of a of a box singing
there is no way that it could possibly
be worth it
i mean 100 million maybe actually i'll
take 100 million but anything less than
that i wouldn't do it
uh let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
evan says it's not taking revenge on
disney when you remove a bonus privilege
that they've been uh taking for granted
i don't think it's a good thing to be
vindictive but this was not being
vindictive this is just treating them
the same as every other corporation
yeah look it's all those things that you
that you said it's true we're taking
away a bonus privilege
uh and as i said i don't even think you
need to justify it any more than that
it's a privilege you don't have any
right to it and we could take it away
it's if it actually is a privilege that
was granted to you by the government
um not a not a natural right imbued uh
upon you by god or as part of your
natural you know um
it's part of your natural rights if it's
a privilege given by the government then
in fact they they can take it away
um
so all of that is true but i also think
at least as far as i'm concerned i'm not
saying this is the legal argument that
desantis make but it it is i also like
it as an act of revenge as well
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with that
you know an act of vengeance
against a mega corporation
that has gone all in on sexually
indoctrinating and grooming children
vengeance against that sure that's great
alexandra says lol lol matt used the
daily cancellation to secretly vent that
mrs walsh doesn't want him to spend all
that money on an aquarium
you know when i started writing
that monologue yesterday i didn't
originally intend for it to be
for the aquarium bit to make its way in
there but it is something that's really
on my heart right now it's how badly i
wanted
an 18 000 aquarium so it did get in
there i suppose
um
trail says i didn't even know about
tunnel digging but now i must have one
it's going to be the most wonderful
tunnel and i can't wait to get started
robin yates says when the digger turns
out to be a serial killer i'm not
letting matt live this down i have
really got out on a limb for this guy
and that did occur to me again as we
were talking about the this issue
i did think
nothing wrong with digging a tunnel it's
every man's dream it's great
um
it's it's slightly serial killer-ish
like there's a little bit of that maybe
just slightly
just a just a whiff that's all
and so if it ends up going that way then
yeah that uh
i have gone on a limb for him so let's
hope that doesn't happen
um
jack says matt you said you would never
do a pre-recorded interview but you went
on dr phil kind of hypocritical no see
that's not hypocritical that's just um
that's me being uh not hypocritical but
stupid because i somehow completely
forgot about dr phil when i said that
and it occurred to me afterwards okay i
did do i did do a pre-recorded interview
i did dr phil my point still stands
though okay
this is where i'm going to give you a
yeah but still thing here because trump
trump should not be doing pre-recorded
interviews with pretty much anyone
especially not piers morgan
um he shouldn't be doing interviews with
piers morgan at all because
why
like any time you do anything as a as a
politician or a candidate or someone in
a political world
and you you know you're doing anything
on camera especially
you should always be able to explain
what the win is like what's the win
how do you how how is this a a win for
you
and i don't see it with a pierce morgan
interview now i could see how it's a win
for him because it's ratings but you
don't need piers morgan you're donald
trump
um and even the dr phil segment's
actually a good example that was a
pre-recorded segment
it was there was a risk it was a
calculated risk
wasn't something i went into blind
so doing the dr phil thing
i knew that yeah okay it's pre-recorded
so and you are kind of signing your life
away with all the waivers and everything
so they can do whatever they want with
the footage and that is the risk
i also was pretty sure that i could
trust dr phil to be fair and now that
risk calculation turned out to
you know worked out
and also i knew that i stood to gain
quite a bit and the message stood to
gain so there's a risk a cost benefit
analysis
risk reward analysis
the risk is they completely butcher the
footage and they try to make me look
like a fool that is a risk
but if that doesn't happen then the
reward is quite substantial not just for
me personally but for the message
and it ended up working out thank god
um
but once again for donald trump what's
you know what's the risk reward what's
the cost benefit analysis
of going and doing
all these different interviews
pre-recorded interviews
you don't you don't need to do that
you know it's not like you're going to
gain publicity from a piers morgan
interview that you didn't already have
would just be nice if there was somebody
in donald trump's circle who could
talk to him about these things but
apparently that doesn't exist
well as the beloved author of the
best-selling children's lgbtq plus book
johnny the walrus i am now a very
important voice in the transgender
conversation that's why i was invited on
dr phil to discuss these most important
issues with experts who couldn't of
course tell me what a woman even was if
you haven't seen it yet i highly
recommend that you check it out and even
more importantly if you haven't picked
up a copy of my best-selling children's
book you should do so immediately it
sold out in 48 hours when it was
released but don't worry more copies are
on the way so reserve johnny the walrus
right now on amazon now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
you know one thing we've learned from
the left during the anti-groomer
discourse is that we're all a bunch of
paranoid lunatics worried about nothing
because nobody's talking to little kids
about sex also we've learned that we're
all a bunch of bigoted prudes because
they are talking to little kids about
sex but that's totally fine so we've
learned both of those things
simultaneously
the thing we're complaining about isn't
happening and also it is happening and
it's okay that it's happening
it's probably my own mental failing that
i can't figure out a way to reconcile
two completely opposite things or
conceptualize how a thing could happen
and not happen at the same time so
instead it's easier to break this down
into pieces and on the it is happening
but it's fine end of the spectrum a
couple of clips from this week are
illuminating the left again when they
aren't denying that any of this is
happening at all claims that they only
want to discuss sexual issues and topics
with children in a developmentally
appropriate way
but what do they think is
developmentally appropriate
well we know the answer to that question
because we've heard it directly from
teachers and we know that what they find
developmentally appropriate is in fact
horrifying insane and perverse
but just to drive that point home here
is jen pasaki appearing on the dearly
departed cnn plus may rest in peace and
perpetual light shine upon it to explain
why exactly kindergarten teachers
may need to talk about this stuff with
their students listen
don't parents have a right to have
concern i mean we're talking
specifically here about teaching about
sex in kindergarten through third grade
i have to say as a parent i would have
problems with that
but the law is not about teaching sex
education it's about teaching about
gender identity and so what what do you
do if a parent or a kid should i say a
kid in one of these elementary schools
says
what about sally sally has two moms or
i'm not sure if i'm a girl or a boy i
mean these are kids who are experiencing
um you know these moments in their lives
i also think that these are not there is
not a big record of there being either
sex education or extensive gender
identity education in these schools and
this is creating a problem or a
political cudgel about an issue that i
don't think exists
so zaki claims that kids in kindergarten
might say to their teacher i'm not sure
if i'm a girl or a boy now here's the
thing about that first of all no child
is going to say anything like that
unless concerted effort has been made to
confuse him so
if a child is going to a kindergarten
teacher with such a query um it's not
because he's reflecting naturally on his
identity but because he's an environment
which intentionally fosters confusion
and if that's the case the answer from
the teacher should be pretty simple if
the child is a boy then she need only
say you're a boy
if a girl then you're a girl
and that should be the end of the
conversation
fortunately um there's nothing in the
florida law which would prevent a
teacher from telling this fact to a
confused child any more than a teacher
would be prevented from telling a child
how tall he is or how old he is if he
was similarly confused about either of
those subjects
but speaking of fostering confusion
the very radical and extreme and
dangerous libs of tiktok account
committed harassment and terrorism once
again
this time against a woman yesterday by
reposting a video that she posted a tick
tock
in the video this woman a mother
apparently and tragically
explains
what is in her mind a developmentally
appropriate way to talk about sex and
gender with a young child listen
here's a developmentally appropriate way
to talk to toddlers about bodies and
gender
you know the body parts that your diaper
or your panties or your underwear cover
those are called privates
everyone has privates
private means that they belong to you
and only you in the front
everybody has genitals
but
there are different kinds of genitals
some genitals
are called a penis
some are called a vulva
others
look maybe a little bit
like each in some ways or kind of like
neither
or somewhere in between
people with those kind of genitals are
called intersex
when babies are born
parents sometimes
guess their gender
based on their genitals
they tend to guess boy for babies who
have a penis and girl for babies who
have a vulva
sometimes parents guess wrong though
and that's okay everybody makes mistakes
sometimes
people whose parents guessed wrong about
their gender are called transgender
so
she says that um here's a
developmentally appropriate way to talk
to toddlers about gender but she
misspoke
what she meant to say is here's an
extremely creepy way to confuse a
helpless young child with a bunch of
insane [ __ ] invented by pedophile
sexologists in the 1960s
tomato's motto i suppose that's what she
meant to say now notice how this pink
haired freakazoid starts off right away
by introducing intersex
to the toddler
rather than giving the basic simplest
facts to the child she spends time
talking about genetic anomalies that
affect like point zero five percent of
the population
now it's true of course technically that
a very small minority of people are born
with physically ambiguous genitalia
this doesn't mean they don't have a
biological sex but just that determining
their sex is a little more difficult in
these very very rare cases
why would you mention this to a toddler
though
it's like if you were on a plane with
your three-year-old and you leaned over
and said so johnny planes go in the sky
sometimes they fly all the way through
the sky and land safely sometimes they
crash and everybody dies sometimes they
blow up in the air sometimes they fly
into buildings
now
that would technically be true but you
wouldn't say that to a toddler unless
you your intention was to traumatize him
because a child that age doesn't
understand statistics or probabilities
or the distinction between things that
are common and things that are rare
you especially won't understand the
distinction when you phrase it in a way
that is designed to make it seem like
the rare occurrence is just as common as
the common occurrence
so you talk to your child about plane
crashes that way if you want him to
think that planes crash all the time and
you talk to your child about intersex
that way or at all
if you want him to think that intersex
is just as common as normal bodies
from here the psycho with the crazy eyes
goes from misleading her child to
straight up lying
she says that parents and doctors guess
whether a baby is a boy or a girl based
on genitalia as i told you last week
this guess thing is the new talking plan
it's the new euphemism
it used to be sex assigned at birth
which was already misleading enough
now it's sex guest at birth
and they go with guess instead of a sign
because
guess sounds even more arbitrary and
baseless and yet and yet they still
admit
that most of the time
the guess is correct
well why would that be the case
why does it just so happen that parents
who guess boy based on a penis are
almost always right
of course they're not almost always
right they're always right but
i mean even based on the demented logic
we heard in that clip
according to her
the guess quote unquote is almost always
right
why is that
if it's a 50 50 guess
and there are billions of guesses being
made across the world
then shouldn't the guest be wrong about
50 of the time
shouldn't 50 of the world be trans
because trans by this way of thinking is
simply the result of a wrong guess
that's all
with so many billions of guesses
how can there be so few wrong guesses
well these are the kinds of questions
that we as critical thinking rational
adults can ask
these are the holes that we can punch in
the nonsense that people like this woman
are spewing
but even the smartest toddler in the
world
isn't going to notice these problems
he doesn't have enough information about
the world to think critically about this
he'll just accept whatever he's told
and he will become deeply profoundly
despairingly confused and lost and that
is all by design that's the plan
by these grooming predator ghouls
and that's why they are once again
canceled
that'll do it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day and a great weekend talk to
you monday godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show you know
some people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin